da gibt's für den hanoi ist gescheitert
man muss wohl auch sagen er ist krachend
gescheitert
und ich bin schon ein bisschen
verwundert denn es wäre möglich gewesen
zumindest eine symbolische friedens
erklärung zu machen oder eine
unterzeichnung die zumindest der
arbeitsebene und den unterhändlern die
prokura gibt weiter auf diesen
friedensfahrt voranzugehen und das wurde
komplett versäumt in hanoi und das
wundert mich dann doch ein bisschen ist
es klar man kann an verhandlungen
zwischen amerika und nordkorea nicht die
gleichen voraussetzungen einstellen es
ist immer ein bisschen anders
das hat damit zu tun dass man nach
jahren dieses lager in den kalten
krieges schon froh sein kann wenn man
miteinander redet aber zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt wäre schon wichtig gewesen
auch konkret einzusteigen in einen
fahrplan zur atomaren abrüstung oder
eben eine formelle friedens erklärung zu
unterzeichnen und nichts ist passiert
das lässt jetzt viele fragen offen und
ehrlich gesagt weiß keiner so richtig
wie es jetzt weitergehen soll
wo ich im letzten jahr war es ja schon
nach dem singapur gic für so dass der
chef unter hinter amerikas und seine
leute kaum termine mit nordkoreanern
bekommen haben es hat monate gedauert
bis man sich auf arbeitsebene hat
verständigen können
und das nach einem jahr aus
amerikanischer sicht erfolgreichen
gipfel
da frage ich mich ehrlich gesagt schon
wie es nach diesem desaster weitergehen
soll
das kann zum jetzigen zeitpunkt noch
keiner beantworten ich auch nicht aber
ehrlich gesagt ziemlich schlecht aus
[Musik]